levitation a trick made famous by
illusionists like David Blaine is
happening in this Tokyo lab for real the
student behind it isn't using magnets
he's using sound it's called
three-dimensional midair acoustic
manipulation what's special about it is
that by altering the frequency of ultra
sound emitted from these four speakers
student yo hei hei has been able to move
the objects in midair unfollow only do
the same slow mo caucus he awakens the
benefit of sound waves is that you can
control them very precisely for example
you can pass something that measures
only one millimeter through a gap that's
only one millimeter or you can move
things only a few millimeters and as
components in electronics get smaller
every day the team sees real uses for
ultrasound they even think it could be
used in space to help move heavy objects
around even humans but to grab the
world's attention y ou H she didn't
publish his findings in a scientific
journal he chose social media
this video on YouTube had nearly three
million clicks by our last check they
develop first of all you had a second or
two before it was difficult to get the
public's attention only by presenting
your work at academic conferences today
it's important to self-publish because
in Japan they're cutting research
budgets as well as breaking new ground
in ultrasound yo itchy looks to have
created a new kind of social science